[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in rick stroud he covers the
buccaneers for the tampa bay times and a
host of sports day tampa bay
podcast thanks for joining us um where
do we stand with this story
well i mean if you talk to jason light
you talk to bruce arians any of the
coaches
you know they they think that
it hasn't happened yet they think it's
possible that he could retire i mean
they were hurt by all this you know
coming out the way it did they sort of
said the media jumped the gun a little
bit eventually tom brady called them
called jason light and told him he
wasn't close to making a decision yet
but
come on now that we just watched his
whole career funeral over the weekend i
don't know if you can come back from
that one um
i keep watching you know highlights of
tom brady so
uh i'd like to announce my retirement on
the damn package show as a guest if it's
over
this would be it i see a year from now
when they get the first overall pick you
know
um but now i you know i i expect it to
happen but dan you know this too you
know there are
i mean really it started friday night
with jason la canfora in the report on
cbs and it kind of stayed out there for
20 hours and we we made our calls and
they were like ah now you know and then
everybody became jason luck confirma uh
at that point because you know we had to
see if this was really happening and uh
you know when you hear adam schefter go
accordingly
i believe tom brady will you know at
that point
you're just like okay it's really
happening now so i i think we're good
gonna see it happen but i think it's
gonna be like a gotham chopra uh
beautifully directed family in tow in
costa rica planting trees it's gonna be
something
that's that's gonna be tom brady-esque
right i mean this guy is like the truman
show sometime i think it's gonna happen
after the super bowl i was told uh
yesterday uh and and on saturday that
they tom wants to control this like they
want to do it in a way that you know
tom's social media has been unbelievable
since he went to tampa bay now you don't
want to have it like spill out where you
got the conference title games the next
day i mean that's just not brady's style
do i think he's going to retire i do
i just think it was more of the
semantics of this that it's going to
happen it's just not happening in real
time do you do you buy into that
timeline
yeah i don't know i mean there is a week
between you know the super bowl so it's
possible with the news out it could
happen anytime really this week um he
might wait until afterwards um i i think
it's probably going to be sooner than
later i mean the bucks aren't you know
dying to know if the answer is i'm
leaving um but they've got to move on
too but it's
you know i i just think that this is
going to force his hand a little sooner
than he wanted it to be and it's you
know you're right he wants to control
this there's nobody going to tell him
when or how he's going to do this so
he'll do it on his own time but um now
that the news is out you know it's
probably coming soon
but i don't know if you're giving
buccaneer fans false hope here like is
he no
no no okay i mean he could be look
there's probably i mean why not cling to
the fairy tale right i mean look these
two years were i've said it it was like
a meteor streaking across the sky it got
bright and there was super bowls and
there was playoff games and all of that
and you know i wrote before the wild
card game and i quoted clyde christians
and saying if i was a fan i'd look at
this as like this might be the last time
we see tom brady um
but no i'm not giving him false hope i
mean i i i trust the guy look the way
this works
dan you know this in the media i broke a
story years ago about bill parcells
having a deal with the bucks before tony
dungy coached his last game well i won't
say who it was there's a guy that sat
next to bill parcells at the mothership
that knew this for weeks but he couldn't
report it because he was going to get
the exclusive and somebody else reported
it instead now what do you do if you
know it's true so i mean you know i'm
not
alleging conspiracy here but i mean i
think that i think that there's probably
a better than average chance that
somebody knew something
uh ahead of time
and once it was out there it's like well
not only is this out there but it's true
so what do we do now you know and the
media couldn't wait at that point but is
is there money attached to this decision
by waiting
no no no money there was no reports
about that
yeah that came out he's listen they they
did some things with the contract and
they deferred a signing bonus until
february 4th which is like this friday i
think and really um if he retires
he owes them a little bit more money
than they own him i think it's like 16
million goes back and 15 million comes
to him so i don't expect there to be a
change of money i've checked with the
bucks they would you know they would
push that back as far as they wanted to
uh if he wants to check if they want to
forgive it whatever um but that is
absolutely not i know it was out there
but that's actually not a factor is why
he's waiting um that sort of made him
look kind of petty and greedy and that
that's just not not true
what are the bucks going to do at
quarterback
oh man
um jameis winston here you go come on
hey he's right down the road yeah he's
right down the road in oldsmar um i you
know right now all they have is kyle
trask on her contract and i suppose you
could resign blaine gebbert um if you
wanted to uh and he could be the bridge
quarterback but look
bruce airings has said they will look
behind door number two that's how they
found tom brady i don't think aaron
rodgers is going to be standing there
because the green bay packers aren't
trading into an nfc team same with
russell wilson um you know can you pry
at a derrick carr do you do you take a
chance on a desean what i don't know uh
maybe maybe andrew luck wants to come
back at age 32. you know i mean they
will look under every rock and and bush
they can but the fact is that uh you
know there's just not a lot of options
right now and they'll have to pay
quite a premium of draft picks if
they're going to do it this is not a
free agent class that they can really
tap into like they did with tom
byron leftwich want the jacksonville job
you know i think he does but i i think
he doesn't want it with trent valkyrie
and i have not spoken to byron this is
just my opinion um you know there were
some reports about adrian wilson coming
over from the cardinals
um look the last three or four teams
bowkey has been a part of they fired a
coach after one year so you know i've
talked to byron before the season about
coaching he's he's definitely wants to
be a head coach but he has no timetable
he was an nfl quarterback has plenty of
money he's going to pick the right
situation for him and i guess new
orleans has him as a candidate as well
it makes so much sense that means the
jacksonville jaguars will screw this up
completely and not hire byron leftwich
bruce arians going to stay as head coach
in tampa
he's told me several times he is i know
everybody thinks that he would leave um
i i guess anything's possible but i
asked him you know with or without brady
and he said no he's absolutely coaching
if he gets todd bulls and byron back he
can have the same process he's already
said that if brady came back and he were
to lose uh byron left which he would
actually call plays again which is news
right and probably a signal to tom brady
but um i i do think he'll coach again at
least next year
rick great to talk to you as always and
uh we'll wait for some more drama down
there do you think that gronk is done
in tampa
as soon as she can get that usa
assurance
he's just waiting for that and then
he'll i feel bad for gronk you know he
he's trying to disguise his voice and
you know maybe he joins the military
rick
then you could get that insurance
exactly now i think he's his future or
lack thereof is probably tied to tom's
he's not played for another quarterback
and um you know they'll miss him a lot
man i'll miss him a lot that's for sure
thank you i we appreciate your time as
always rick thank you that's rick
stroudy covers the buccaneers for the
tampa bay times host of uh sports day
tampa bay